sup guys Jerry coming at you live and
direct I'm crew them right now whoa I'm
on my way to aaron's place we're gonna
get dank we're gonna talk alone talk
about some cinnamon and I we're gonna
talk about the sled that you guys can
see we're gonna talk about the slider
man cuz we just watched that movie
always watching that's right the Slender
Man motion picture
coming out of the YouTube arena in to
the cinema and you know as some stuff to
get to grab on there you know it's a
it's an interesting little flick and
we're going to talk about that statement
rock and roll ham sandwiches I feel very
strange all of a sudden I but nothing
old talk cannot cure so
you
Wow the great thing about the Internet
is that space-time doesn't [ __ ]
matter see for all you know that was
like a 10 hour break this is tomorrow
but you're hearing this all truncated as
one experience you have no idea where we
are we might not even be in Burbank yeah
we could be dead by now we could be dead
we could be dead by now but hey you know
what at least we have experiences to
bring us together and experiences like
going to go see of spooky mais oui mais
at Tara ween spooky days Sarwan spooky
day there was food days folks a place
for everyone where childern ken spooky
that's that's the official slogan of
this simply the greatest uh yeah a new
attraction hey sorry this is many pages
long and they don't have a great grip on
on on the whole stack of anything so I'm
adding yeah so the pages are numbered
with like a big drawn number across most
of the text yes little weird um new
attraction at arch at our contractions
yeah meets on hook meets on hooks too
many o's meets on hook is also food
court is also the food court that's a
man that is there such a prize there's
like a photo that looks like time from a
slaughterhouse yeah side of beef on a
hook hey Matt a rusty ass hook I mean
that's a really good why not you know if
you can make something spooky and you
know cost-effective it's like hey you
meets on hooks is a scary thing but hey
you can also have someone will cook it
through I hope they cook it I mean it's
always weird cuz like cooking on we've
got the hospital from a parts of the
area works like you know you you sit
down you have a burger and it's like a
scary monster walks by you but you don't
feel threatened because just like well
he's not gonna interrupt my meal yeah so
like here it kind of breaks the illusion
but here's like the food court is really
creepy looking yeah what I mean you know
making it so that you gotta go in to
creepsville and hack yourself up or have
somebody hack off piece of food for you
yeah you know I
I really hope they cook this this stuff
yeah I don't want it to be wrong yeah
cuz beef sushi is not a thing that
sounds appetizing at all nah dude I have
eaten I will admit a real talk hashtag
real talk live on air I have eaten raw
ground beef before oh really yeah how
was it is good it's good i want to eat
it yeah the person i was i was hanging
with its time it was her Jam it's like a
secret sort of a predilection how do you
I mean what do you do with raw data just
ate a hunk of it you don't like mix it
with anything you don't like put salt in
it or I'm sure it would be just good
that way because I mean you know it's
like yep like too deep okay the tuna
poke a works like raw fish that's mixed
with a sauce what sod sue she's like the
greatest i love sushi any kind of raw
fish deal is is the jam if I why can't
we get a sushi spot I mean not that I
don't love our friends at terry's you
want it may be one of the meats on hook
it's just like a big like half of
albacore I really has that would be okay
if they have if they have you know a
pescetarian or even your vegetarian
option um you know I love you I feel
like meats on hook does not have a
vegetarian option for whatever reason
you never know I'm in words I don't I
don't know where this is from exactly
but I if there's enough demand you know
I imagine I have to meet it so um yeah a
terribly scooter I really hope they keep
sending us these yeah I really hope they
do do we want better schooling or worse
spelling cuz we're smelling would make
things a little interesting have you
ever read carrot facts yes there's
nothing bad spelling cannot do there I
don't a shout out on Twitter to care
y'all use a Twitter just go search up at
real carrot facts I found this [ __ ] on
the Internet I don't I don't know how
maybe it was like through a retweet or
something but I do I went to real carrot
fact in fact I'm gonna follow this on
the dank ass Twitter right now um if it
is one in a series of these like really
silly Twitter's that are like supposed
to be kind of one thing but then they
sneak these weird little
storyline like coffee dad yeah was he as
a copy that's always tweeting like just
little things that said coffee or time
for some coffee brewing a fresh product
coffee and then randomly it'll be like
my sweet angel who left us all these
years ago please don't drink and dress
like it'll have these weird really dark
kind of sad story lines inherit faxes is
one of those where it's just a dude who
tweets these silly not actually real
facts about carrots and then randomly
pines for his ex-girlfriend implements
the fact that he can't connect with his
dad and his dad thinks he's gay but 5 16
15 s is from couple weeks ago most
carrots like a PSVita pet detector
because it stars Jim carrot alrighty now
this is I I hope terribly spooky days is
not pranking us and this is actually
just like a fake not haunt didn't even
say where words hosted or anything yeah
I don't know I mean I imagine we'll get
more details come October yeah most
carrots have the crunch I looked at
Megan's facebook page before bed last
night and it made me feel not good
carrot is spelled with the sea but it
sound like a que I don't want to dial up
speaking of speaking of haunts kind of
like starting to roll too early alone is
like starting its new its new phase in
July yet dad you jus and the month
yellow really hell ya soon Jesus yeah
get on it so Ernie was anyone in the LA
area looking to get spooked out of their
mind in a very philosophical and kind of
ambient way check out alone I love alone
I mean alone was was my favorite haunt
from last year yeah and I mean you know
cuz like extreme haunts have become a
big thing now you know it seems like the
normal theme park stuff while fun you
know and then the sort of carnival style
approach to tohon's you know is still
very popular but now people want more
people want you know to sign paper so
they can actually be a costume like
there's there's become a cottage
industry formed around all the [ __ ] you
can't do it a theme park anymore it's
like what do they take out that part
can't touch it we're gonna do that yeah
and just make everybody sign stuff um
but alone occupies this really cool
space there there in la haunt and I
think they it was made by like these art
students so it has this slightly more
it's slightly more intellectual service
ethereal aesthetic going on you know and
it's it's got these it has like a sort
of social media presence where it has
this sort of strange new agey new agey
voice and it's always very conceptual
and the show they did the last October
was was very cool and almost beautiful
in a way like it was it was creepy and
scary but also like unsettling and weird
it was a common kind of like a David
Lynch movie um but it was you know you
go through it alone and there are all
sorts of different scenarios and and
what I liked about them is it it's not
always like all right now we're gonna
yell at you and spit on you and okay
come into this room we're gonna dunk
your head in water you know like they
got actually very creative with the
approach to how they were going to creep
you on in it is sort of as they as they
put it they they are really succinct in
their descriptions of themselves because
you know it was just an exploration of
fear and loneliness and was very relaxed
after we we did an earlier vintage tank
episode about like a scavenger hunt that
they did in between vintage dank it's a
good year ya know it's 20 it's an
earlier dança episode that was out on
the on the now you know kind of closed
for now soundcloud and we'll find it
we'll find a way to reboot some of those
old episodes so you guys can be
commentary on a few other things yeah it
still exists it's like it's still of
it's just you know we got to sort out
gotta sort out the financials maybe pick
up some more sponsors because like I
think YouTube is actually kind of a cool
place to put these but i would like to
also have a soundcloud yeah onand you
know in case I don't know if God forbid
I mean you know cuz we've got you know
god forbid we picked up some haters
ma'am but like yeah hey hate that word
we picked up some negative feedback
however you know sudden want to be like
you know
smug in asserting this but you know if
people want to download episodes take us
with them in the car if they like us
enough you know I would like for that to
be a thing be an option wall so lord
knows like premium dong saying premium
done son she's got a she's got a you
know find a way to work in her her DANC
doses hey premium dongsaeng man shout at
sea we there are a lot of shout outs on
this channel and I feel like a dick
because I'm like you gotta hurt a shout
out you know like you can't just can't
just have everybody like grab an atom
right premium dongsaeng has
distinguished herself on the comments
board very happy about that also a shout
out to Yusuf Ashraf I always watch and
always talking at us you know always
given some feedback yeah very happy to
see you on the boards and who's that one
guy where were they where is he shoutout
to come on I'm surfing the internet
right sure shout out to the people who
are like what is this [ __ ] yeah we're
just like confused don't read the
descriptions and I don't know I don't
remember where the comment was but a
shout out to that guy who hates us yeah
Achilles Cooper yeah where is he i want
to say a acrylic Cooper oh yeah this
guy's always commenting yeah that's
Achilles or a sillies Cooper shout out
to you like that's not as well Achilles
at all yeah I don't know I don't know
exactly how to how to quite pronounced
this but um but thank you for commenting
on all of our videos with some form of
either perplexity or just negative
feedback I mean cuz you know I angry and
confused yeah like I don't know as of
yet it's not really that bothersome
which is nice you know and I mean you
know I do understand these are kind of
rough around the edges we're figuring
out our jam in our slide and you know
how are these will change over time no
they won't maybe not yeah the next
actually we're just going to be
recycling the same three topics every
episode the next one is gonna be about
ex machina it's gonna be ex machina yeah
gorgeous always gonna do that psycho ex
machina fury road and then Marble
Hornets yeah maybe we'll switch the
order up just to just to really confuse
people on april fool's day we will
on April Fool's Day we will release a in
fury road episode instead of instead of
a marble hornets one yeah you know funny
thing is we get so many direct messages
on this Twitter yeah and I don't the day
get the official day and get stuff sort
of slide indeed those d-ends bro yes
line in the DM so uh yes a Mad Max
pretty rough right you know it's that
it's like I wish there was more to talk
about with with with always watching but
it feels like everything is just kind of
gonna be like yeah I was interesting
what they do with the characters and you
know it's like you know what they did
with you know the property and the
horror stuff for marble hornets it feels
like they kind of just stripped that
away and and distilled it one thing that
was weird was you know they make a big
deal of the operator can only be seen
through a camera yeah whereas in in yeah
the original web series you get the
sense that you can just kind of see the
operator at any time it's like you don't
want to see him and part of its like you
can see him at any time but it's like if
you're trying to capture him on a camera
it will bug out on you yeah and the
camera bugging out is like an indication
that he's close but you haven't quite
caught him yet sorry aside now we just
got a comment on another video during
this recording nice from premium dog sex
crazy of dogs so don't say you know
where a premium dongsaeng t-shirt max
according get get a t-shirt print out of
that that jay pop star that is her
avatar hell yeah i forgot her name I
think she's actually kpop I'm sorry Josh
[ __ ] rich I'm sorry I'm out of here
thank you [ __ ] out so terribly spooky
dish or no spot oh he's back all right I
went to the apology hole did you think
about what you don't you well then had a
long think it's a lengthy in length to
do that's not a bathroom we didn't go to
the bathroom no it's the Apollo
okay well I mean a bathroom would be a
pretty good apology home this wasn't the
bathroom I don't I don't do that well
well done I mean I would love to know
your secret odds cuz I mean pooping is
just a sort of unfortunate fact of life
you know it's like everyone's someone
asked what the [ __ ] is [ __ ] on one video
what the [ __ ] is [ __ ] well you know it's
a byproduct of digestion now and your
body taking nutrients and then the sort
of expelling what it doesn't mean but ya
knows like there's a whole this sort of
recurrent uh the roundabout discussion
about like the whole girls don't poop
thing and I was like you know what it's
it's not about that for me I don't want
to hear about anybody pooping because
yeah pooping is is an unfortunate fact
of life we all have to deal with poop is
never glamorous or pretty or-- cool it's
it's like a sort of prone and kind of
icky thing we all have to deal with so I
don't want to know about anyone's please
its own time to be with someone tries to
make like a reverse sexism argue about
something kind of like that's not good
on either end it's like oh you know it's
like you know why is there this whole
myth about girls don't poop I'm like why
are you so invested in hearing about
anybody shitty yeah it's like I don't
want like the whole deal like oh why can
you why can you hit a guy but you can't
hit a girls like well you should be
hitting be somebody anyone might be
punching people and I mean maybe we
should all focus on perhaps not hitting
it yeah exactly I don't want to hit
anybody yes like I want to hear about
you [ __ ] it's like it makes
everything on it I kind of feel like if
there's a situation where it's
appropriate to punch anybody like it's
appropriate to punch them regardless of
gender like if someone is a serious
credible physical threat to you I think
like hitting back is like well you got
who yeah if like if you're in a
self-defense class and you've got as far
with the partners like you you kind of
have to punch them that's that weird
like good-natured sexism words like well
I don't hit girls at the same time like
well someone's going to hit them and
they're paying to be in the self-defense
class yes like people are just people at
a certain point someone is assailing you
yeah you
you can you know retaliate yeah you know
it's not about cuz then it's about the
situation but now it's not taking the
preservation like I i took crop classes
for a little bit it's like none of the
women that i ended up on occasionally
getting paired with like had an issue of
like they want to ask like no just hit
me the way you would hit anybody cuz
like I'm here to learn how to defend
myself and yeah I'm not if you're like
going easy on me then that's not helping
me yeah same with poop yeah sound puh
just just don't talk about your proof I
don't want to know yeah I want to know
about anyone no one I don't want to see
an Instagram your [ __ ] I I don't go out
of my way just I don't you know I don't
extolled lengthly lengthly tomes you
know dedicated to my poop expand just
don't get the people that are like proud
of like taking a really big [ __ ] that's
just like I mean not to say that in the
sanctity of your own lavatory you can't
be like man I can't believe that pass
through my system but like this between
you and your God like like behold what
is in your toilet and maybe make a
comment if it's worth it to be like wow
that's a surprising appearance yeah and
don't let me know about like like just
as a good rule yeah you know if there if
somebody like [ __ ] on this like in high
school somebody [ __ ] on the staircase
look like that was worth hearing about
because it's so outlandish it's like why
is there why is there a log just on the
stairs to the second floor use this like
why you know or if somebody like there
was [ __ ] on the ceiling one day like
that's extraordinary like okay maybe we
can that's when's achill to me yeah but
you know so how does that happen if you
just left a righteous deuce behind and
didn't flush like I don't want to know
just it's also like if you if you didn't
flush [ __ ] you yeah yeah I wish I really
wish I want if I ever did stand up I
want to find a way to tell like really
sophisticated creatures like go ahead
and try like you know just bill hicks
george carlin ass poop jokes
goofy you're a braver man than I didn't
want you know for willing to attempt
that I would not attempt that I would
always I'm not a very good stead i am
not a very good stand-up at all i feel
like i could maybe get there with a lot
of focus but I'm much morning prob mine
I feel like I could do stand-up I just
couldn't handle stand-up culture I
believe that one yeah but you can carve
out your own [ __ ] man you get on that
open mic see ya wait let's trace back
poop MarbleHornets marble hornets that's
the thing with a pectus back to topic
and this thing about the marble hornets
movies like for a found-footage movie
it's pretty cool like it's it's me it's
like it's oh this is like the stuff i
like about it i really like and it's
like better than I thought I expected to
enjoy it but it's like it's better than
I thought but in not in the department
that I was expecting anything in you
know just in technical execution more
than myth Oh sir or you know
interestingness and that's yeah it's
like a weird like it's it's not a bummer
because i liked it i feel good will
towards the movie but at the same time
it is kind of a bummer because it's like
Oh stepping up into feature-length
territory and it sort of pairs down the
mythology and kind of narrows it yeah
and then going back to the whole thing
about like it can only be seen on camera
you know again I like that sort of
disconcerting element that marble that
the the web series had where it's like
it's like yeah you can see him it seems
like they could actually see the Slender
Man but also it's like sometimes he'll
show up just on the camera sometimes
he's in the room it's that further
distortion of what reality is so she
starts appearing to you and it's also
like there was that thing in the web
series of like you know you would see
something on a on a videotape that you
don't remember yeah yeah exactly whereas
usually seems like in the movie if that
ever comes up it's usually like I don't
remember this but it's on teh way and
then it's it's all very close to the
ground it's like oh I get it like you
know any any lapse in space-time is
always kind of explainable whereas in
Marble Hornets there's always sort of a
blue yeah I like it subverts cos found
footage like is a problematic genre and
a lot of people hate found footage I
don't I mean we could do a whole episode
about found footage I feel like you know
I'm not upset at being a found-footage
mood cuz like you know the room of
Hornets his game out MarbleHornets his
counselors the web series is found
footage the thing about though
Slenderman that makes it creepy was like
you know it was originally built as a
found-footage kind of thing where it's
like you know the Son of Man was born in
the thread works like hail it's like you
know take our photoshop skills and let's
make like fake archival spooky
paranormal images yeah and out of that
idea was born the Slenderman so it's
like the what made it creepy what makes
the Slenderman creepy is like he seems
so much older than you you know it seems
like something he seems like something
that was in your life before you could
remember yeah and so that gives it a
kind of a creepy power over you mm-hmm
you were saying meets on hook man no
something no yeah yeah I mean it comes
away and that's sort of something the HD
does too is like it comes away from that
low finest because like it's born of a
loaf I thing and so if you're gonna do
it now it's I feel like it still kind of
behooves you to have that sort of
anesthetic yeah you know instead of
qualitatively who knows I mean maybe
this isn't the last we've seen of a
marble horsemen on marble hornets beer I
mean I feel like there's more that can
be done with this property and this
isn't this isn't the fullest that you
could do with the Marvel Barnes movie
yeah like its legit okay it's a freak
it's a it's not I'm moving yeah it's
station yeah and it's you know need to
have the Slenderman around yeah but it's
just not like like disconcerting and
strange and mine bendy yeah you know
it's like I can see why this was a VOD
title yeah and it works well bore yeah
because then I feel like watching it in
your living room sets you have to be
like oh oh this is cool like you know
yeah you can have that sort of like this
is
neat yeah you know this kind of played
out for me not maybe an even more mellow
way because like when I have reviewed
unfriended you know I felt pretty
positively toward that movie in in a
very sort of mellow way but it was like
oh you love that movie so much like no
it just did a lot of things right you
know like and I appreciated it I don't
love it but I'm like I feel kind of
similar about this I'm like oh yeah like
meat good job is some clever stuff here
are some really well done stuff over
there like you don't have to get out
there and watch it this minute but it's
pretty good like you you know I feel
feel benevolent towards it well I would
say I mean if you have the time to burn
I would say go through the marble
hornets web series oh hell yeah because
I mean like that you know it's like it's
more you know don't expect like the most
cohesive like super involving story but
the creep factor in the end of fear
factors I think a lot stronger in the
web series than it is in in the movie
well and then I mean that goes to the
medium again too because it's you know
it's not a vlog but it's just a guy sort
of chronicling this thing he's doing
with little web entry so we don't need
extraneous story about like what's his
fairly life like it's just it's just
supposed to be a guy posting these
things to his youtube page so you know
you can it's just not required whereas
the movie I guess you kind of have to
you know I'm something going on yeah
like that and there you know it's hard
to do especially in found for like any
any character stuff is always hard to do
in a found footage film you know cuz you
gotta find a way to get it out in any
sort of a natural way and in very
compressed time that's what I liked a
lot of unrest time it's like you know a
found footage movies that they take
place in a form of real time so yeah
how'd you get those moments out you know
and you know it's as far as the the you
know as far as the the mythology is is
portrayed in the movie it almost feels
like we see a lot of the characters just
trying to guess at the ghost rules for
the operator yeah where's like you know
they set up writers rather setting up
what it does really early and and you
know what it's about really early it's
just kind of like you see Milo and
Charlie and and Sarah just kind of
sitting around like thinking this is
what it does it makes you go crazy or
makes you kill each other makes this
happen makes that happens all a lot of
supposition it's almost like like for
instance you know they have the whole
thing of like oh you can only see it in
the camera what we all just turned the
cameras off that was a cool moment man
edges as a conceptual thing like you I
like that idea to me it just kind of
felt I don't know to me but I don't want
to say cheap but just didn't quite
strike me the right way where it's like
oh yeah you know it's like let's turn
off the cameras and maybe see it'll stop
hunting us and then they trough the
cameras and then they turn the cameras
back on it's like it still [ __ ] [ __ ] up
somehow they just weren't around to see
it yeah no I mean I don't think you know
what time is it ok I don't think it
handles it great but I just did like the
acknowledgement of like hey we've been
obsessing we've been recording it what
if that's exactly what it wants from us
what if we stop and I my my movie by
madness movie I would have handled it a
bit differently yeah but uh cuz i mean
it's it's a cool idea to have it you
know have the people shooting the
found-footage movie just think what if
we'd stop recording and actually stop
recording but to me it almost felt like
you were setting up the rules of it only
shows up in the camera and then you're
just kind of saying [ __ ] you when people
address that fact and just kind of like
rewriting the rules of this thing on the
fly and not in a knot in a kind of an
intelligent way miss Erlene yeah no I
get you what I think really should
happen is they cut the camera off a few
minutes of black
and then just superimposed tiles that's
just say like you know they turn the
cameras off and live happily well some
props movie ends at the 45 minute mark
lesson is don't recall yourself yeah
just uh just show with the the cell
filming all the time yeah I mean I yeah
I mean I don't I think it was a neat
thing to attempt like I said I don't
think they that's not how I would have
executed that idea of her I like I like
going into it yeah I'm this sort of
subsequent like whoo yeah and then
coming back out of it isn't as
satisfying well cuz then just become 0
comes more the same thank you you know
it's just like well that's it's that
didn't work here's this idea dad you
didn't work yeah keep going hey cuz I
there was never like I a new big broad
change outside of you know what dog dies
oh it's wrong which was sad you know
it's like yeah it's it will just of all
the movies to kill the dog yeah yeah
it's a little like yoga trending you
know got twisting kinda cool emotional
beat but it yeah it doesn't like change
anything with the characters really
outside of you know they're a little
more sad and morose and defeated feeling
and nobody likes when done done no
nobody likes it except for I know some
kind of dog killer people what cat
people I think even cat people like you
and dogs I well cause of your campers in
your animal persons yeah drink a person
you like annum no just um except I have
a very hard time imagining anybody who's
like I only like cats [ __ ] all the rest
[ __ ] every other animal you want a horse
[ __ ] that horse I hope it dad yeah it
seems like a very outlandish thing yeah
so be good three things people yeah it's
it's got some guts and charm it's got
some good good elements it's got some
mmhmm yeah it's mildly good yeah it's a
it's
the meat yeah it's the it's not picante
good yeah it's it's got some charm it's
got some some you know laudable
qualities but I don't know man it's like
I yeah it's like if the original web
series was like that plucky kind of like
renegade film student that was just
doing whacked-out stuff in class I was
like really unique and rough around the
edges this is oh hey you got a studio
job he's not really doing anything super
creative but you know it's good that
he's pulling some extra dough and I hope
he gets back to doing big creative stuff
yeah and maybe it's just up to you know
up to the kids that initially created
MarbleHornets to kind of see what other
properties or whether what other
projects are gonna launch into from here
are they going like is this hormone like
they have a they have a kind of a
YouTube thing going on by haven't
checked out a whole lot yet well just
under the Troy has a camera tha see
banner and um I mean they got to be
doing okay financially to sunny Singh
because like Troy Wagner is a dad now
I've [ __ ] yeah I'm not kidding like and
he's a youngish dude I think oh yeah you
said what and I mean I got imagine they
they they got partners or something yeah
I got imagine they've seen some money
off the episode oh yeah they're there
yeah there I think they were you two
partnered with the marble hornets
episodes and I think you know they have
a story credit on this movie so as movie
was you know for a feature film that was
made on a tight budget it has tubes you
know made some stuff back over plz your
entire budget went to double this entire
budget was Doug Jones's day rate this is
doug jaws and like even the camera
rentals are just all the [ __ ] they're
using leg on screen yeah so this all
shot like me I'm DSLRs Oh God maybe
that's part of why you found footage is
so so you know what comp footage is so
popular as a genre because it's you know
camera rentals are suddenly a lot
cheaper because you're you're using
prosumer break cameras instead of you
know a high
same yeah or you can just you know get
some people together or even you know a
three-thousand-dollar camera can produce
not a great image but a pre a good
enough image for that you know it's like
the amount of these things that are
probably shot on 5ds it's like you pull
together three grand and there you go
now you can make a million or you can
rent it out to your friends you know
there are a million ways to make a
found-footage movie on a shoestring on
the fly and that is a gift and a curse
because so many of them come out that
clearly are more made in service of the
means than any actual story that needs
to be found footage but there are a few
that slip up worth like yes like you
really like that is what I appreciated
about unfriended was I was like okay I
get why this movie was on you know skype
and on computers like it makes sense if
that's what the story is about yeah it
wasn't just like well what's cheap well
we could do it on skype yeah why not
lightning like it actually had a reason
to do that and and that if unfriended
was made on tighter budget they would
have to use like msn instant messenger
yeah we've had to just go back a decade
it's a really really juicier but it's
just all damn and you're just reading a
conversation uh oh it's like subtitles
the movie God just your eyes being
pierced by that white background pool no
yeah you know like so that's that
there's a reason there are a billion
lackluster found footage movies all over
the internet you know because anybody
can make one and that sort of separates
you know you know looks like a proving
ground it's like if you could make one
of these halfway decent you've got
something because I've worked on some
some found footage that wasn't so so
successful with them yah yah yah yah so
it does it takes a lot more than just
like well we've got a space and a camera
let's make a movie you really got a
found footage is almost harder in other
ways because II there are things to
justify their logistics you know in
terms of like where and how you would
point a camera and what people do under
stress yeah
you gotta keep up the illusion way more
lies what bugged me about like there are
good things about as above so below but
like at a certain point I swear somebody
picked up the camera and just pointed it
at their face while they're screaming
and running from something I was like oh
I don't I don't get you just wouldn't do
like and then you get pulled out of it
you know so it's hard it's a hard thing
and then head it's like that was a movie
where you could really feel the script
because the guy he's on madman who plays
um he plays a Ginsburg right the way
love and he's on silicon valley but he's
in a he's in a blah blah and his
character spends there's one scene where
they're like we're going to this
catacomb and he's like no I'm not going
down there as he's walking toward the
hole in the ground to get in and he's
like he's like no I'm not going in there
as he strolling up and then he's
climbing down he's like no no way you're
not getting me down there as he's
lowering himself into the thing and it's
like clearly the script needs you to and
they're trying to make you seem like a
person because you don't want to go but
this is not a convincing moment at all
it's like it's it's like that's a very
scripted like moment where someone's
like oh no I'm not doing that cut to
them doing it except this didn't even
cut him doing it he was doing it while
he said he wasn't gonna do this was the
star yeah so it's like that just feels
like that's something that belongs in a
comedy yeah it was kind of a silly
moment and and and that's that's a
really intermittent movie because like
the character II stuff a lot of it
anyways is kind of weird and thin and
like because the movie needs to have it
there and then the scary stuff is really
spooky like so like the down-low
brothers clearly know how to make you
know chills and scares and stuff like
that but yeah I'm interested to see I
mean his pal footage is kind of his own
genre I'm interested to see if like
there will be any other further film
project based around the Slenderman cuz
you know marble horns is its own thing
you know the Slender Man is even called
the Slender Man Marvel horsies the
operator so I'm wondering if this under
man will become a film property because
the rights owners are Erik Knudsen who's
Victor surge you're going to create the
character and signed off on
marble horns and signed off on the
marble parts movie and then there's some
weird other rights holder that no one
knows about who has never been named
it's not public knowledge they just the
dude who became this lemon it is the
actual Slenderman his life rights yeah
but no there's some mysterious unknown
extra rights holder that is yet not
public knowledge to find it yeah it's
like who is this who is this person that
owns the partial rights to the
Slenderman somehow by some weird back
alleyway we should do some kind of
really weird like you know kind of slice
of life documentary called searching for
Slenderman is I was going on the roads
two guys on a road trip like the car is
always filled with like food wrappers
and soda we're just like we drive across
the country look this guy who started
with the Eric nudes who talk to him now
he's sending us to Delaware to meet the
next person and then when we don't
actually find anything but we did grow a
lot and learn some things about lying if
we find we find like this shack where no
one lives that's like the best lead
we're ever gonna get it's yeah it's like
at the end of the day use is still you
know pretty much in an igloo you know
you touched a lot of lives along the way
but a store is really told the people
you left behind and we and we along the
way we interview people around the
country who have been involved in the
Slender Man in some way like you know we
get to troy wagner and joseph delage and
then we get to help people that are and
you know people that were involved in
like the the the actual like children
killings out words are not connected to
it i'm wondering maybe that's part of
what's keeping on more slender man
properties out there because i know the
slender man has kind of been referenced
in other ways in TV a lot well my
wondering if like what's keeping people
from getting into making more slender
man properties the fact that you know
just just with him being an internet
meme there's been you know violence
connected to the myth oh yeah well the
internet is a tenuous place to get
anything no but it's crossed over like
video games 02 I mean there's a lot of
indie games that are based on the
Slender Man
I just know about slender yea which was
like an indie game eh but some people
okay well guys I mean a lot of people
are talking about it i guess its it had
a reach it seemed like and i think a big
part of the reach of slender was because
it was a forward game that was kind of
cheap and quick and easy so it's like it
was popular among the youtubers set Oh
Candice interplay no but I'm curious I
imagined it's kinda like you know five
nights at Freddy's works like you know
people play this video game to film
themselves screaming yeah and put them
on the Internet I mean it did make me
want to try it yeah you did make me want
to try yeah I'm curious isn't a I'm like
5 unlike part for now like how do you
keep pumping that game up five nights
are slender fabulous I think slender
only has two yeah well I mean the new
version of five nights like they're
super spooky nightmare versions of all
the characters good yeah now that's a
rack of the real rejects need to get
into playing spooky video games on
camera I think Ryan is already working
on something like that fan tastic yeah I
own the rights that idea though well or
as I'm concerned get Ryan on the horn
because uh hey uh you could do it and
then come on the show and talk about who
was just saying the day who would who
love to come on the show oh no picking
up a Rolodex of guest spot you're gonna
start figuring that [ __ ] out yeah you
guys start asking who wants to come too
dank studios I know at least one guy a
good guy you met him before but y'all
haven't so again keeping secretive yea
sorry I'm trying to look up this game
slender slender ya son again slender the
eight pages I really what's under to the
knife page I just have wood and not an
issue that this page has some issues
yeah this page has some issues I have aa
damn i can't play it's only on microsoft
oh no it's not always tended um I have
something of an issue these days with
subtitles do just because like nowadays
everything has a subtitle
lots of things have subtitles hey always
watching colon a marble hornets story
yeah it's like those things kind of
bothered me like when they remade the
thing part of me was like well you're
just coming at the thing but at the same
time it's like they had a couple
subtitles ones are thinning the
beginning or the thing sub-zero
awakening or something like that ending
revengeance yeah and like just something
about like however we approach those
kinds of titles today bothers me it was
gonna be the thing the beginning or the
thing awakens and there's something just
that bothers me love those titles now
yeah I almost feel like I would rather
things just be called just call it
slender yeah slim too until we get this
[ __ ] figured out i mean the eight pages
ain't bad but yeah and you know it's
like what for instance Mad Max is a
franchise it's all about like a
different adventure every movie so you
know having to be mad max the road
warrior Beyond Thunderdome fury road you
can understand that yeah one those work
you know it's like the road wart like
that hi cuz that's another title like
that works or you know beyond
thunderdome could be a thing on its own
yeah fury road could be a thing on its
own yeah you know there was something
about like you know it's like Exodus
gods and Kings I was like yeah yes in it
you're gonna just call that Exodus yeah
and I really wish I could figure out
what it is that bugs me so much about
those it's just something bugs me about
a lot of these subtitles it feels
awkward to me that always watching
became always watching colon a marble
hornets story well that was just I'm
almost certain that was just to you know
in case there was any and if you you
can't overlook it now if you it's like
oh the people who are into marble
hornets will find this if we put that in
the title yeah physically we just slip
out our VOD thing called always watching
yeah nobody might see and that's also
like if it's just called if you just
title it marble horns because it's you
know the movie version of that franchise
it's like because it's a side story it's
not based on the main story of marble
hornets it becomes very like you know
where's the connection because marvel
horns the web series was about
some guy tracking down the footage of
marble hornets the in-universe student
film by got cam so you can't really call
this marble hearts because there's
nothing in the movie connected to Marble
Hornets outside of it being in bed that
broader universe yeah one it also you
know it saves you the time uh if you
don't call it a marble hornets story
people don't pick up on the Easter eggs
people might be like who's a ripoff more
worth yeah and that saves you from that
argument so I get it like I get a marble
hornets story enemies first Easter eggs
to outside of like you know the thematic
connection and the like operator rules
that that pop in here and there the only
real the only real easter egg was like
there's they go to a gas station alabama
and there's a missing person's poster
for Alex Crowley who's the you know
selling beef jerky yeah what this is an
ad for Alex probably beef jerkies there
Joe yeah I'll be gasps oh there's a
missing person's ad for for Alex prolly
who was like you know the dress of the
lodge character who went missing in you
know in the web series it was the guy
making the student film so dude what
charlie is the star of the limitless TV
show what is the deal with the limitless
TV show I know next to nothing about the
one of those two either but he's been in
some [ __ ] he was Biggles American sniper
who that's [ __ ] his Biggles an American
sniper Charlie Charlie the [ __ ] boy yeah
Charlie boy isn't he was in live free or
die hard which did he do he probably
died hard I guess so hard oh dude the
first time I would say the first time I
said die hard diehards rad the first
time I saw die hard was it a die hard
marathon with Matthew and uh that that
was kind of a bummer marathon hindsight
it was a cool bonding experience like
and I hung out all dark for 20 hours
watching John McClane movies but there's
20 hours of John McClane movies well we
they're not 20 hours what am I saying 12
ish hours okay you know cuz ever breaks
in between um so by the time you know 52
hours like technology we were there for
a long time and that is a marathon that
that really deteriorates like like you
good die hard which is [ __ ] on like
die hard like I really really enjoyed
die hard like it's a it's a really
well-made action movie die hard to it's
all right like it's it's it's perhaps
you know a bit blown in a bit campy but
it's still like it's so pretty cool and
John McClane still John McClane part 3
is actually I dug part 3 with him and
Sam Jackson and stuff like that and then
part 4 rolls around and part 4 is like
it's kind of fun but he's just Bruce
Willis now yeah and it's like that
moment where John McClane faces off
against a fighter jet you like you know
you've crossed over yeah and this guy's
not a human anymore you know and then
die hard 5 is just a bummer ya like like
die hard whatever that one was call it
forget with the subtitle the new title
was but die hard 5 was such like waiting
die hard 5 yeah whatever the fifth one
was good for your die hard no let Linda
the thumb lift lid free not three free
live free or die hard was the fourth one
cuz I'd team at the elephant okay and
that was the one there was pg-13 uh oh
that's right there have been two new
diehards in like the past few years
haven't there been yeah there was that
whole thing of like oh yeah they're
going back to the r-rated die hard and
then it was not a good thing oh where is
it a good day to die that's right with
Jai Courtney who Hollywood really wants
us to love like like Jai Courtney is in
every action movie now um which is more
recent a good day or the freer a good
dad a good day was the last how many
years are between the two of them
because they just ran together in my
mind uh no there was some time let me
see let me like 2013 for a good day to
die hard
and oh yeah that's right he's in for
Lola's video um and live free or die
hard was 2007 what time was in Russia
but that was a good day to die hard that
was number five those only came out in
2013 oh my god we're like ain't nobody
givin a [ __ ] that whole movie like there
there is a scene where a helicopter is
firing a machine gun into the side of a
building and a car crashes into it yeah
and you don't even hear so much as
sirens until they are well on their
they're out of that situation of well on
their way to the next play it's like the
Russian police don't seem to give a [ __ ]
that like massive destruction is
happening all over the city John McClane
is just an [ __ ] who doesn't care
about massive dammit like people are
clearly dying as [ __ ] in Russia but like
but speaking of death speaking of death
yeah you know when I want to go to see
some like really death death ass [ __ ] is
the so many there are we supposed to
read them all this is a book we're gonna
have to go over like multiple episodes
um that's like if you want seem some
more dying ass [ __ ] you can go to the
terrifying neurons of taraweeh spooky
days yeah like that hominis [ __ ] like
that like that was on a cassette head
was sent in with all the pages Oh bless
these people okay uh so do you wanna
know it says on the cassette it was it
says like play this one doing the
talking hey it was like a weird sentence
that made no sense like that maybe we
should play this the whole show cuz all
we do is talking we are we are always I
assumed it was like talking's regarding
tyrants few days with just all these
pages and pages of copies yeah whoever
they built / totally graph paper by the
way I I just really want to see the
inner workings of the headquarters
wherever they make here uh so yeah turn
spooky days introducing a much much new
fun show a bunch new fun show uncle
Janish insult comedy jokes show
okay so so it's like you know like the
the insult theatre that I do you must
yeah he's it's like this weird like
Ukrainian affable peasant looking man
with a big mustache and a giant hat yeah
so if you're if you're looking I guess
for some equal opportunity offense its
kind like the insult Emporium that they
had at Universal that one year was at
Chuck you right yeah like the hanging
show at Knott's Berry Farm I guess what
see what it takes to take that uh go
uncle Janish bring much laughs he said
and there's a quote it's of jungle
Janish as i guess i'd go hey hey there
sugar woman go you to push my cart you
eat too much breast uncle jana uncle
Janish make much laughs he will cause a
riot no it sounds like I mean it sounds
that sounds like a matching energy
potentially misogynistic material just
calling someone a sugar woman I just
push his car she's a very agrarian type
of I'm gonna call every water sugar will
do you have a car too I'll get a card
damn it love you want you and thank you
too uncle yatta just um and more
sponsorships please yeah more do we want
sponsorships that are more broken
English or less broke more broken
English more the more off brands and
like broken english ii you know if we
could get a sponsorship and carrot facts
notes i would pimp their [ __ ] sure
nobody is your business reliant on
broken english and just really arcane
undecipherable instructions then please
please hit us up take a stubbs at gmail
com and we can feature your business
yeah you know you have a business that's
what we'll do instead of shaq-asso yes
or just plug businesses until someone
gives us our bizarre business that's our
nowhere terylene spooky days is yeah
they're on a weekday get on like a
tuesday afternoon listen I gotta take a
day off work so I can so I can go to
this weird Ukraine and spooky haunt I
need some fresh meats haha I gotta go
through this spider I need to go to
check out yeah the spooky man's that's a
spider whatever that means obviously
shaped like a spider's spider themed is
it I think there's probably like a maze
and it's probably there's spider inside
the to know where you know it's like it
so this is like a reptile house which is
one spider in one tank yeah I mean you
know kind of like a like a one of those
like special tents for those like a
carnival attraction so I come in and see
our spider that's a crazy ass spider so
thank you tara ween spooky days Thank
You Terry spooky day sponsoring us they
didn't give us any money but they just
they just says they just send us an
email saying we are sponsoring you yeah
there's money but I feel like they took
the time to make us a cassette and to
you know print this [ __ ] out and they
emailed us a copy they mailed us the
email printed out with a cassette oh
yeah you know so it's like they took the
effort why not yeah you know which is
weird I'm kind of concerned as dad they
send in here we don't have a p.o box oh
yeah there was no return address on the
thing it was just like on the doorstep
yeah so okay why not yeah I assumed the
mail guide fraud it but maybe he worked
for it yeah made the mail guy maybe it's
like you maybe he saw the flag outside
dank ass headquarters yeah stately dank
manner and was just like these people
need to spread the word yeah probably
his really his uncle Janish the mailman
is probably trying to wrap his uncle
Janish is Halloween Haunt that he has
every year Dahlia problem ask him next
anything I need to see like what's that
documentary about people that make at
home haunts Oh American is it called
American Nightmare yeah it's something
like that yeah something like that maybe
terylene spooky days is featured in it
yeah that out and do another Hans
episode next time
that's your homework for the viewers at
home it's like watching american
nightmare please let us know what Tara
ween spooky days is yeah yeah so yeah so
Slenderman Slenderman we're always
watching Marble Hornets and story story
story in the marble hornets Cinematic
Universe everybody's got a cinematic
universe now yeah in the marble hornets
animatic universe there's a missing kid
in Alabama and and a dead [ __ ] boy in a
very nice lodge that his company I would
like to kick a dead for missing Alabama
and a dead [ __ ] boy this is something it
sounds like a some Southern gothic
burger Bala just like I was sitting by
the fire with an Alabama this boy did
football either that or like some kind
of quirky like fun espionage movie was
like we cobbled together this ragtag
team to see a lot imagined a dead [ __ ]
boy this was all we can pull together
out of moment's notice it'll have to do
that's red three right there yeah with
me yeah whoo well it's been fun don't
laughs we learned a lot don't don't
watch any you know mysterious DV tapes
while we're gone we'll see y'all next
week and once again I am NOT Jerry and I
am NOT Aaron and we are definitely not
[ __ ] we're not but i hope god i hope
that i don't like you wouldn't know if
you were [ __ ] boy is it various like one
of those things like you if you wake up
in a cold sweat and just had this toner
coursing through your body every night
like that's your indication that you're
a [ __ ] boy yeah maybe it's like it just
kind of haunts you at night I don't know
where you're wearing some kind of long
draping knee length shirt yeah yeah
where'd this come from oh that so that's
the that's the black Twitter [ __ ] boy
because there are multiple species of
[ __ ] boy of everything nothing can exist
for very long without having multiple
subcategories Charlie in marble horns
very much white [ __ ] boy away
yeah alright I won't make the same
mistake I want to I want someone to make
like a fuck-boy chess set where it's
like the white [ __ ] boys are all like
you know Ivy League pastel polo
boardshort you know wearing wearing a
pea coat even in summer hell yeah like
uh you know want to be Don Draper
schmucks and like the black side of the
[ __ ] boy chess set is all like you know
dudes are trying to be streetwear with
the pyrex shorts in the Supreme bandanas
underneath a supreme ball cap don't you
insult my man man no don't you dare
insult my method I will never insult a
hat I'm coming to the end of an era I'm
almost there and I can't take it I'm
sorry it's okay don't worry about it
maybe we can get a sponsorship from [ __ ]
boys yeah organization is there like a
[ __ ] boys United I feel like you know if
you if you subscribe to the theory that
no no all press is good press you know
it's like we talked about [ __ ] boys a
lot we talked about [ __ ] boys in a grand
total of two episodes yeah hey that
ain't nothing yeah we can go for four
shouts out to all the [ __ ] boys I came
out of material whoo and to the Internet
as well we love you love you and once
again kids stay bank